How do
we see things around us?
You will probably say it is EYES that help
us to see the
objects around us.
But will your eyes be able to see these objects
in dark?
No, we need LIGHT to see things!
Without light, we cannot see the objects!
But
where is this light coming from?
This light is coming from this source which
is a
fluorescent bulb!
You see that this bulb is emitting its own
light.
The objects
which emit their own light are called LUMINOUS
OBJECTS.
Can you give me any
other examples?
Incandescent light bulb, the sun, the stars
are also luminous objects!
What about objects such as this table and
chair?
Do they emit their own light?
No, these objects do not emit their own light!
Such objects are called NON-
LUMINOUS.
Almost everything around us is non-luminous.
Objects made up of
wood, plastic, cotton, metal are all non-luminous!
What about the moon and the planets?
They are also non-luminous!
But if the
moon is non-luminous, then how come we are
able to see it at night?
The answer to this is REFLECTION OF LIGHT.
The reason we are able to see any
nonluminous objects around us is because of
reflection of light!
Reflection of
light can simply be referred to as CHANGE
IN DIRECTION OF LIGHT or bouncing
of light from some surface.
Just like the ball bounces back from the ground,
light reflects off from a smooth surface.
Let me try to explain this in a simple
way.
The light from the source strikes the object
and bounces off from its surface!
And when this light reaches our eyes, we see
that object!
And this is how we
see NONLUMINOUS OBJECTS!
When the object is kept in front of the mirror,
its image is formed in it.
But will
we be able to see the image in the dark?
No we won’t.
So the formation of the IMAGE is also due
to reflection of light.
Let this object be our human body, so at the
same time we are looking at the
image!
First tell me, is our body a luminous or a
nonluminous object?
Well it is
nonluminous!
Human body cannot emit its own light!
So the light from the source is first incident
on the human body.
It gets
reflected from it and this reflected light
strikes the mirror.
This light is further
reflected from the surface of the mirror and
reaches our eyes!
This is how we
are able to see our image!
Now obviously this is not exact picture of
the
happenings.
I just wanted to give you the intuitive feeling
into how this
happens.
There are lot of subtleties involved which
we will learn in our higher
grades!